My name is Diakalola Amujam. I am a recent psychology graduate from Ireland. I am also an aspiring clinical psychologist. Dr. Marion's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, has been so helpful to me on this journey to becoming a clinical psychologist. As I plan to continue postgraduate studies in the UK, I found it extremely useful that this book provided in-depth information on the UK. the Clean Sight application process. I enjoyed reading about the experiences of both qualified and training clinical psychologists. The various narratives were my favorite part of the book, as everyone's story was different
我叫 Diakalola Amujam。我刚从爱尔兰心理学专业毕业，也是一名有志成为临床心理学家的人。Marion 博士的书《临床心理学家集体》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）在我成为临床心理学家的旅程中对我帮助很大。由于我计划在英国继续攻读研究生，我发现这本书提供了关于英国临床心理学申请流程的深入信息，这非常有用。我很喜欢阅读那些合格的临床心理学家和实习生的经历。书中的各种叙述是我最喜欢的部分，因为每个人的故事都不尽相同。
and it provided amazing insights into the clinical psychology journey. I would definitely recommend this book to anyone interested in psychology and aspires to become a clinical psychologist. People working in mental health often avoid linked to. because they're scared of getting it wrong. But what if avoiding it was the actual mistake? Today's guest used LinkedIn to find a masters, connect with leaders and even speak on a TEDx stage.
它为临床心理学之旅提供了令人惊叹的见解。我绝对会向任何对心理学感兴趣并渴望成为临床心理学家的人推荐这本书。从事心理健康工作的人通常会避免使用 LinkedIn，因为他们害怕出错。但如果说“避免使用”本身就是一个错误呢？今天的嘉宾利用 LinkedIn 找到了硕士课程，与行业领袖建立了联系，甚至登上了 TEDx 的舞台。
We are talking about why visibility, specifically on LinkedIn, doesn't have to be risky and how it might help advance your career in a safe and even a fun way. Hope you find it so useful if you do, come and connect with me on LinkedIn, where I'm Dr. Marianne Trent, and like and subscribe for more.
我们正在讨论为什么保持可见度（特别是在 LinkedIn 上）并不一定有风险，以及它如何以一种安全甚至有趣的方式帮助你提升职业生涯。希望你觉得这很有用，如果觉得有用，欢迎在 LinkedIn 上与我联系，我是 Marianne Trent 博士，也请点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。
Hi, welcome along to my own. the podcast, I'm Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist, and today I am joined by Shirin Yazdian. Hi, Sharon. Hello, thank you so much for having me. Well, thank you for being here, and thank you for being my LinkedIn connection. I, as you know, I'm a big fan of LinkedIn, and you were like, I think we should get more aspiring psychs on here because this is really a good place to be. Could you tell us why you think that, Sharon? So I kind of had this idea that only finance students or people in corporate roles post on LinkedIn and it's only to find jobs and because, you know, in psychology, we tend to apply to jobs
嗨，欢迎来到我的播客，我是临床心理学家 Marianne 博士，今天和我在一起的是 Shirin Yazdian。嗨，Shirin。你好，非常感谢邀请我。嗯，谢谢你的到来，也谢谢你成为我在 LinkedIn 上的好友。如你所知，我是 LinkedIn 的忠实粉丝，而你当时说，我觉得我们应该让更多有志于心理学的人加入这里，因为这确实是一个好地方。你能告诉我们你为什么这么认为吗，Shirin？我之前有一种想法，认为只有金融专业的学生或从事企业工作的人才会在 LinkedIn 上发帖，而且这只是为了找工作，因为你知道，在心理学领域，我们倾向于匿名申请工作。
anonymously. Having a LinkedIn profile doesn't seem very relevant to me. But actually, the more, actually, really you inspired me to go on LinkedIn. And the more I looked into it, the more I realise the value of connection and learning that comes from LinkedIn. So that's why I think more aspiring psychologist or psychologist or anyone in healthcare needs to be on LinkedIn. Yeah, and as I said to before we hit record, even last week I was having a conversation with my husband and I said that I'd got 19,000 connections or followers on LinkedIn now. And he was like, that'll be helpful. It really is.
拥有 LinkedIn 个人资料对我来说似乎不太相关。但实际上，你激励了我去使用 LinkedIn。我研究得越多，就越意识到 LinkedIn 带来的联系和学习价值。这就是为什么我认为更多的心理学准从业者、心理学家或任何医疗保健领域的人都需要在 LinkedIn 上活跃起来。是的，正如我在录音前对你说的，就在上周，我和丈夫谈话时提到，我现在在 LinkedIn 上有 19,000 个联系人或关注者。他说，那一定很有帮助。确实如此。
LinkedIn is not what you think it was. For me, it's where you can be yourself first and then your profession or whatever you're doing second. And people are choosing to connect with you as a person because they like the way that you see the world. And maybe you'd make them laugh because, of course, about a year ago, maybe a little bit longer, LinkedIn introduced the laughing emoji, which was really part of the humanising aspect of LinkedIn, I think. Does it make you laugh? Do you have a bit of fun on there as well? Yes, I do.
LinkedIn 并不是你想象的那样。对我来说，它是你可以先做你自己，然后再考虑你的职业或你正在做的任何事情的地方。人们选择与你建立联系是因为他们喜欢你作为一个人的样子，喜欢你看待世界的方式。也许你会让他们发笑，因为大约一年前，或者稍微久一点，LinkedIn 推出了笑脸表情符号，我认为这确实是 LinkedIn 人性化方面的一部分。它会让你发笑吗？你在上面也会找点乐子吗？是的，我会。
Actually, I've got lots of comments from people throughout the time that I've been posting, like a little bit more than a year, that like some comments have been funny to people that I've posted, but I think I was just being my authentic self. Yeah, absolutely. So I like to post on LinkedIn,
事实上，在我发帖的一年多时间里，我收到了很多人的评论，有些评论很有趣，但我认为我只是在展现真实的自我。是的，绝对是这样。所以我喜欢在 LinkedIn 上发帖，
but I also like to engage in other people's content. And sometimes I think people think, oh, maybe I'm not interesting enough to post something or, you know, maybe I'm not psychological enough to post something, but I think it's okay to speak to whatever kind of grabs you, whatever's taken your interest. You know, it might be psychology related. It might, it might not be. Like one of my favorite LinkedIn connection is Dr. Amy Jane Needham. She regularly talks about her rats. She's a forensic psychologist. And I would say, whatever floats your boat, if you're being authentically yourself, that's kind of okay on
但我也喜欢参与别人的内容。有时我觉得人们会想，哦，也许我不够有趣，不能发帖，或者也许我不够“心理学”，不能发帖。但我认为，谈论任何吸引你的、引起你兴趣的话题都是可以的。你知道，它可能与心理学有关，也可能无关。比如我最喜欢的 LinkedIn 联系人之一是 Amy Jane Needham 博士。她经常谈论她的老鼠。她是一位法医心理学家。我会说，只要是你真实的一面，无论你做什么，在 LinkedIn 上都是可以的，
LinkedIn, would you agree? Yes, 100% have fun with it. Like I do think, you know, like, the first post kind of feels a little bit cringe, especially because we see lots of posts of people like announcing that they got a job or announcing that they want a prize, which is really exciting and good for them. You know, I really root for that. But at the same time, it can be a little bit daunting to post anything but that or, you know, to post that you got a great, you know, achievement or a great result for your undergrad. But I think when you add a little bit more authenticity in it and a little bit more of you, as you just said it, makes it really fun and engaging and, as you said, more human. And I found that to be one of the main reasons when I reach out to people that we can actually,
你同意吗？是的，百分之百同意，玩得开心点。我确实认为，你知道，第一篇帖子感觉有点尴尬，特别是当我们看到很多人发帖宣布他们找到工作或获得奖项时，这真的很令人兴奋，对他们来说也很好。你知道，我真的很支持这一点。但与此同时，除了这些之外，或者说发布你获得了一个伟大的成就或本科成绩优异的消息，发任何其他内容都可能有点令人生畏。但我认为，当你加入更多真实性，更多你自己的东西时，正如你刚才所说，它会变得非常有趣、引人入胜，而且更人性化。我发现这是我联系别人时最主要的原因之一，我们可以真正地，
I can, you know, get a reply back or I can just have a chat with them, learn from them. And yeah, I feel like it can be a little bit cringe to post first few times and put yourself out there. But you get a lot out of it and there's a really lovely community out there that you can connect with. Yeah, I think the same is true for social media generally. It can feel difficult to put yourself out there. I think especially if you're starting out in business as well. You think, oh, people aren't going to be interested in what I think or say. No, they're not going to care.
我可以，你知道，得到回复，或者只是和他们聊天，向他们学习。是的，我觉得前几次发帖并展示自己可能会有点尴尬。但你从中收获颇丰，而且那里有一个非常可爱的社区，你可以与他们建立联系。是的，我认为社交媒体通常也是如此。展示自己可能会让人感到困难。我认为特别是如果你刚开始创业的话。你会想，哦，人们不会对我所想或所说的感兴趣。不，他们不会在意的。
And I would say LinkedIn is likely the place where people will care the most. So, yeah, I would think, you know, you're okay to be yourself. and to, you know, say hello to the world, I would say, because it's international, isn't it? So I do kind of, I connect more with people in the UK, but I do look at people's job titles and their backgrounds when they send me connection requests. And if I'm interested in them and their story,
而我会说，LinkedIn 很可能是人们最在意的地方。所以，是的，我认为，你可以做你自己，并向世界问好，因为它是国际化的，不是吗？所以我确实更多地与英国的人建立联系，但当他们给我发送好友请求时，我确实会查看他们的职位和背景。如果我对他们和他们的故事感兴趣，
and I think we might be able to have some good chats, I do accept international people as well. Yeah, I think it's a really good way, actually, to learn about how other people, people do things and learn about, for example, you know, like I'm interested in clinical psychology to hear what people do in Asia. What are the things on their mind? What are, you know, the values that they talk about on social media? I always find that to be also something really interesting that I would have not, you know, learned any other way. So yeah, I do really like connecting with
并且我认为我们可能会进行一些很好的交谈，我也会接受国际人士的请求。是的，我认为这实际上是一个了解其他人如何做事的好方法，例如，你知道，我对临床心理学很感兴趣，想听听人们在亚洲做什么。他们关心什么？他们在社交媒体上谈论的价值观是什么？我总是发现这也是一些非常有趣的事情，否则我可能无法通过其他方式了解到。所以是的，我真的很喜欢与
other people. And actually, I just got invited to talk at a conference in Canada. So, you know, like, yeah, you can also have fun, get invited to things that are maybe a little bit outside of my comfort zone, for example. Yeah, absolutely. So this can take us to in real life stuff, can't it? And actually, one of my biggest pleasures this year has been taking stuff offline and making it IRL. So meeting up with a couple of people I've only ever seen online, many of whom I actually connected with for the first time on LinkedIn. And that's been a real treat. And I'm looking forward to hopefully catching up with Dr. Dana, who is the killer psychologist over on YouTube. Don't know if you or anyone else listened to our episode, but she's American.
其他人建立联系。事实上，我刚刚受邀在加拿大的一次会议上发言。所以，你知道，是的，你也可以玩得开心，受邀参加一些可能稍微超出我舒适区的事情，例如。是的，绝对是这样。所以这可以带我们进入现实生活中的事情，不是吗？事实上，我今年最大的乐趣之一就是把线上的东西带到线下，变成现实。所以和几个我只在网上见过的人见面，其中许多人我实际上是第一次在 LinkedIn 上建立联系的。这真是一种享受。我很期待能和 YouTube 上的临床心理学家 Dana 博士叙叙旧。不知道你或其他听众是否听过我们的那一集，她是美国人。
And we did an episode together about kind of childhood trauma and kind of what led her towards her career in psychology. And I love it. Like it's one of my favorite episodes ever is like she really slowed me right down. I think it's something about her kind of American. an accent just made me really thoughtful and I really I'm hoping that we can get together in person because that would be really lovely like it's just you never know who you might connect with who you might get on with really well oh yeah that's really exciting yes 100%
我们一起做了一集关于童年创伤以及是什么引导她走向心理学职业生涯的节目。我喜欢它。这是我最喜欢的剧集之一，她真的让我慢了下来。我想是因为她那种美国口音让我变得非常深思熟虑，我真的很希望我们能亲自见面，因为那会非常可爱，你永远不知道你会和谁建立联系，你会和谁相处得很好。哦，是的，那太令人兴奋了，是的，百分之百。
totally agree with that and I feel like you know from perspective of a student so I just graduated I've been able to reach out to lots of people ask for their advice on multiple different things you know, like on applying to conferences, on asking for, you know, kind of recommendation on how to draft a master application. And I do say I've reached out to maybe like 20 people and three, four people have replied back for like, you know, one question that I had, but four or five people have replied back and they helped me a lot. So yeah, I think it's very exciting to connect to people and also provide value as well, which I think is another thing that sometimes as aspiring psychologist, we forget that we can also provide value on our LinkedIn by,
完全同意这一点，我觉得，你知道，从学生的角度来看，我刚毕业，我已经能够联系很多人，就多个不同的事情寻求他们的建议，你知道，比如申请会议，询问，你知道，关于如何起草硕士申请的建议。我确实说我联系了大约 20 个人，三四个人回复了我，比如，你知道，我有一个问题，但四五个人回复了我，他们帮了我很多。所以是的，我认为与人建立联系并提供价值是非常令人兴奋的，我认为这是有时作为有抱负的心理学家，我们忘记了我们也可以通过以下方式在 LinkedIn 上提供价值：
you know, commenting on other people's posts. If something, you know, sparks an interest, if we've read a really interesting article on that topic, like I really, really enjoy. Just, you know, putting in a link to an article under someone's post when they're talking about something or when they're asking for recommendations. And yeah, I feel like there's so much value that we can also bring to LinkedIn that we often forget as students. Definitely. And I think one of the real benefits of LinkedIn is that because it's your name that you're using, then anyone that you're commenting with or interacting with will begin to learn your name, will begin to kind of associate your name with what kind of comments you might say or what you might have to offer.
你知道，评论别人的帖子。如果某件事，你知道，激发了兴趣，如果我们读过关于那个话题的一篇非常有趣的文章，比如我真的，真的很喜欢。只是，你知道，当别人在谈论某事或寻求建议时，在别人的帖子下放一个文章链接。是的，我觉得我们也可以给 LinkedIn 带来很多价值，而我们作为学生经常忘记这一点。当然。而且我认为 LinkedIn 的真正好处之一是，因为你使用的是你的名字，所以任何与你评论或互动的人都会开始记住你的名字，开始将你的名字与你可能发表的评论或你可能提供的建议联系起来。
And then I think that resonates with them in a different way. So of course on Instagram, you know, you could be my favourite cat 84 or something. And that's not necessarily helping someone to know who you are or hold you in mind in the same way. So yeah, I think it's the ability to be seen and potentially to network for job opportunities. And as you found even education opportunities, you said that you'd found out about your master's that you've just completed on LinkedIn. Yes, that's where I first actually came across it. So I really enjoyed my master's. It was psychology and neuroscience of mind and body interface at IOPPN, King's College London.
然后我认为这会以不同的方式引起他们的共鸣。当然在 Instagram 上，你知道，你可能是“我最喜欢的猫 84”之类的。这并不一定能帮助别人知道你是谁，或者以同样的方式记住你。所以是的，我认为这是被看见的能力，以及潜在地为工作机会建立人脉的能力。正如你发现的，甚至是教育机会，你说过你在 LinkedIn 上发现了你刚刚完成的硕士课程。是的，那是我第一次偶然发现它。所以我真的很喜欢我的硕士课程。它是伦敦国王学院 IOPPN 的心理学与神经科学心身接口专业。
And honestly, it was the exact, it was exactly what I needed. And it just one day popped up on my LinkedIn feed. And that's how I learned about it a few months before the applications opened up. So yeah, honestly, there's no limitation to, I think, what you can find on LinkedIn. find on LinkedIn. I've actually gone to lots of really interesting talks that I found on LinkedIn. I found really cool charities to volunteer for because I saw that their values really aligns with mine. So actually, I first saw a conference, a student conference on LinkedIn a few months after I joined. And I pitched a talk 20 minutes before the deadline. So I'm ADHD,
老实说，这正是，这正是我的需要。有一天它突然出现在我的 LinkedIn 信息流中。这就是我在申请开放前几个月了解到的。所以是的，老实说，我认为你在 LinkedIn 上能找到的东西是没有限制的。我实际上参加了很多我在 LinkedIn 上发现的非常有趣的讲座。我找到了非常酷的慈善机构去志愿服务，因为我看到他们的价值观与我的非常一致。所以实际上，我加入几个月后，在 LinkedIn 上看到了一个会议，一个学生会议。我在截止日期前 20 分钟提交了一个演讲。所以我有 ADHD，
dyslexic, and I do tend to leave stuff quite last minute and I applied to that one quite last minute. I got a slot to give a talk and I loved it. I had so much fun. It was in Leeds. I was living in Brighton. I went just for a 20 minute talk. I loved it. I had so much fun. I actually won a prize for the presentation that I gave, but more importantly, that gave me an opportunity to connect with people that really aligned, like their values that really aligned with mine, their aspirations. really aligned with mine. And yeah, I started working for future front line.
有阅读障碍，我确实倾向于把事情留到最后一刻，我申请那个申请得相当晚。我得到了一个演讲名额，我喜欢它。我玩得很开心。那是在利兹。我住在布莱顿。我只是为了一个 20 分钟的演讲去了那里。我喜欢它。我玩得很开心。我实际上因为我的演讲获得了一个奖项，但更重要的是，这让我有机会与那些真正志同道合的人建立联系，他们的价值观与我的非常一致，他们的抱负与我的非常一致。是的，我开始为 Future Frontline 工作。
I don't know if you've come across them or not. It's a not-for-profit charity for aspiring and aspiring healthcare students and healthcare students. And yeah, I met so many really awesome people and they really encouraged me over, you know, the last two years that I've been volunteering with them to try new stuff. And lots of them have come from LinkedIn
不知道你有没有遇到过他们。这是一个为有抱负的医疗保健学生和医疗保健学生提供的非营利性慈善机构。是的，我遇到了很多非常棒的人，在过去两年我与他们做志愿者的过程中，他们真的鼓励我尝试新事物。他们中的很多人都来自 LinkedIn，
and has come from, you know, connecting. those people on LinkedIn, seeing what they do, going over their profiles, getting inspired. You know, that was actually on LinkedIn was the first time that I learned you can apply for TEDx talks. Before that, I thought you get, you know, you're approached for a TED talk. And I do know that happens as well, but I thought that's the only way that you can do one. But no, I start on LinkedIn that you can actually pitch a talk and someone actually in Future Frontline, which again, comes from LinkedIn, told me once after I gave a talk, a different talk, that they think I should go for, I should go for it and I should apply. And that was actually the first time that I thought about
并且来自，你知道，与 LinkedIn 上的那些人建立联系，看看他们在做什么，浏览他们的个人资料，获得灵感。你知道，实际上是在 LinkedIn 上，我第一次了解到你可以申请 TEDx 演讲。在此之前，我认为你会被，你知道，你会被邀请参加 TED 演讲。我确实知道那也会发生，但我认为那是你唯一能做到的方式。但不，我在 LinkedIn 上看到你实际上可以推销一个演讲，而 Future Frontline 中的某个人，再次强调，来自 LinkedIn，在我做了一个演讲，一个不同的演讲后告诉我，他们认为我应该去尝试，我应该去申请。那实际上是我第一次考虑
going for it myself. And I got it. I pitched a talk very randomly. I didn't know that at TEDx NHS, when you go to their event, they have a pop-up that you can just pitch a talk. And I just pitched a talk and I got it. And it was very exciting, very fun, honestly, a lovely experience for me. And yeah, I did a talk on how we can support nor divergent healthcare professionals in September, which was super fun. Sorry I got distracted. Well done. No, it's all relevant, isn't it? It's come from LinkedIn. I've never done a TEDx, and I have to say, you know, I will share with you and with our audience, I don't think I'm interesting enough. I don't know. Please. Oh my God. I can think of like,
自己去尝试。我成功了。我非常随机地推销了一个演讲。我不知道在 TEDx NHS，当你去参加他们的活动时，他们有一个弹出窗口，你可以直接推销一个演讲。我只是推销了一个演讲，我就成功了。这非常令人兴奋，非常有趣，老实说，对我来说是一次可爱的经历。是的，我在九月份做了一个关于我们如何支持神经多样性医疗专业人员的演讲，这超级有趣。抱歉我分心了。做得好。不，这都是相关的，不是吗？它来自 LinkedIn。我从来没有做过 TEDx，我必须说，你知道，我会和你以及我们的听众分享，我不认为我足够有趣。我不知道。请。天哪。我可以为你想到 10 个不同的主题，你会做得非常棒。这对这里来说会超级有趣。谢谢你的信任投票。即使是我们这些说了很多话的合格心理学家也可能有冒名顶替综合症。但是，是的，比如在舞台上讲 20 分钟的想法，比如我不知道，我不知道我会有什么要说的，或者谁会想听。但如果你正在观看，如果你正在收听，如果你认为我有一个有趣的 TEDx 想法，请在评论中告诉我们。
10 different topics for you that you'll be amazing at it. And it will be super interesting for here. Thank you for the vote of confidence. Even us, even as qualified psychs who talk a lot can have imposter syndrome. But yeah, like the idea of taking to a stage for 20 minutes, like I don't know, I don't know what I would have to say or who would want to listen. But if you're watching, if you're listening, let us know in the comments if you think that I have got an interesting idea for a TEDx.
因为也许那会把我推向正确的方向。但是 Shireen，如果人们真的是 LinkedIn 的新手，或者他们已经 10 年没上过线了，有没有一种快速的方法可以让他们考虑优化他们的个人资料？所以我的首要建议是确保你有一张漂亮的头像照片并使用你的全名。你认为 LinkedIn 上还有什么效果很好？
because maybe that will shove me in the right direction. But Shireen, like, if people really are brand new to LinkedIn or they haven't been on for 10 years, is there like a quick kind of way that they can think about optimizing their profiles? So my top tip would be make sure you have a nice headshot photo and use your full name. What else do you think works well on LinkedIn?
所以是的，我认为头像照片是第一位的。我还有一个横幅。我认为出于某种原因，这让它看起来更专业，发挥创意，玩得开心。绝对是个人资料图片，尽量让它更专业一点。我认为当你放入你所做的事情、志愿服务时，它不需要是，你知道，比如如果你是学生，它不需要是，你知道，你想到的是你获得报酬的非常具体的工作。它们可以是志愿服务，它们可以是像在咖啡馆工作，但思考并反思你从那个角色中获得了什么，或者
So yeah, I think the headshot is the first thing to go. And I also have a banner. I think for some reason that makes it more professional and get creative, have fun with it. Definitely the profile picture, try to have it more on a professional side. I think when you put in the things that you've done, volunteering, it doesn't need to be, you know, like if you're a student, it doesn't need to be, you know, you're thinking of like very specific jobs that you've got paid for. They can be volunteering, they can be like working in a cafe, but think about and reflect on what are the things that you are gaining from that role or
你过去获得的。把它们列成要点。有一个简介，一两行，说明你感兴趣的内容。我认为当你有一个完整的个人资料，并且你联系某人或评论某人的帖子时，如果那是你感兴趣的内容，你更有可能得到回复。然后我认为另一件事是思考你能从 LinkedIn 得到什么。你想要从中得到什么。因为你知道，正如我们所说，你不能真正申请。所以对于大多数与心理学相关的工作，你不能真正通过 LinkedIn 申请。所以人们不会看到你的个人资料，顺便说一句，这是一件好事。我不是说那不是一件好事。我认为我们正在匿名化申请是件好事。但是的，看看你能从中得到什么。所以对我来说，
you've gained in the past. Have them in bullet points. Have a bio, one or two lines, say what you're interested in. I think when you have a full profile and you reach out to someone or you comment on someone's post, you're more likely to get a reply if that's something you're interested in. And then I think the other thing is to think about what can you get from LinkedIn? What is something you want to get out of it. Because you know, as we said, you can't really apply. So for most psychology related jobs, you can't really apply true LinkedIn. So people won't see your profile, which is a good thing, by the way. I'm not saying that's not a good thing. I think it's good that we're anonymizing applications. But yeah, see what you can get from it. So for me,
我意识到倡导工作对我来说真的很重要。这就是我想在 LinkedIn 上做的事情。通过这一点，我了解到，好吧，如果这是我的目标，我该如何建立我的个人品牌？我的个人品牌是什么？所以有点像去学习那个，思考你的价值观，比如我们在反思实践中所做的很多事情，把那个带到你的 LinkedIn 上。我认为那可以是一个好的开始，不要觉得你需要发帖。我想也许前几个月，如果你觉得舒服，只是观察，比如，评论，如果你可以，在你的评论中增加价值。在你的评论中加入你的反思，如果有一天你觉得舒服可以发帖，那就去做吧，
I realized that advocacy work is really big for me. And that's what I wanted to do on LinkedIn. And through that I learned that like, okay, so if this is my goal, how can I build my personal brand? What is my personal brand? So kind of like going and learning about that, thinking about your values, like lots of things that we do in our reflective practice, bring that to your LinkedIn. And I think that can be like a good start and don't feel like you need to post. I think maybe for the first couple of months, if you feel comfortable, just observe, like, comment, if you can, add value in your comments. your reflections in your comments and if at one point you feel comfortable to post go for it and
我会是第一个点赞你帖子的人。是的，我觉得那可以是一个很好的起点，去思考你想要什么。你只是想找到你可以参加的活动、会议吗？因为那是我做的另一件事，我在过去两年里找到了 20 多个讲座去参加，或者我可以申请的不同会议，即使它们已经过去了，即使有人在反思那个会议。你可以把它放在你的日历里，明年申请。是的，我认为那是一个很好的起点。非常好的起点。
I will be the first one that likes your post yeah I feel like that can be like a good starting point to think what you what you want out of it do you want to just find events conferences that you can go to because that's another thing that I've done I found like more than 20 talks to go to last two years or like different conferences that I can apply to even if they're past like even if someone is reflecting on that conference. You can put it in your calendar for next year to apply for it. Yeah, I think that's a good starting point. Very good starting point.
是的，我认为只要稍微思考一下当别人进入你的页面时可能会怎么想。所以对我来说，我不接受任何没有个人资料照片的人的好友请求。所以是的，老实说，我认为 Instagram 也是一样，你应该在 Instagram 上放上你的脸，而不是，你知道，一只猫，或者如果你是一家企业，不是你的品牌标志。因为对我来说，你知道，这是“了解、喜欢和信任”的一部分。人们想看到你是谁，如果可以的话，尽量不要过度过滤，尽可能自然地
And yeah, I think just having a little bit of a think about what someone might think as they land on your page. So for me, I don't accept any connection request with someone without a profile picture. So yeah, and I would say the same with Instagram as well, to be honest, like you should have your face on Instagram, not, you know, a cat, or if you're a business, not like your brand load. because for me, you know, it's part of that no like and trust. People want to see who you are and not too heavily filtered if you can kind of tolerate that either, like as kind of naturally you
展示自己。但是是的，我知道社交媒体对心理健康领域的人来说可能很棘手，因为他们会想，嗯，我不一定想让我的潜在客户，或者如果我的经理或首席执行官看到我这么说，那个和那个。你会怎么考虑与有这种观点的人交谈，Shirin？所以实际上，这是我反思了两年多的事情之一。我认为随着时间的推移，我对它的看法发生了很大的变化。因为我倾向于谈论我的大脑。我倾向于谈论神经多样性。我使用很多我自己的例子，因为那是我乐于分享的事情。
as possible. But yeah, just, I know social media can be tricky for people in the mental health space because they're like, well, I don't necessarily want my potential clients or what if my manager or the CEO sees me saying this, that and the other. How would you kind of consider speaking to someone with that viewpoint you're in? So actually, that's one of the things that I've been reflecting on for more than two years. And I think with time, my perspective on it has changed a lot because I tend to talk about my brain. I tend to talk about neurodiversity. And I use lots of my own examples because that's something I'm comfortable sharing.
事实上，我从很多不同的人那里得到了很多反馈，也许这不是一个真正的好主意，我真的很感激，因为我知道那些人真的很关心我，我真的很感激他们花时间去思考它，并带着那个反馈回来找我。有很多点我有点怀疑我在做什么，思考如果这是个好主意，如果我表现得很专业，你知道，比如作为一名学生，总是有这种，我认为如果有人合格并工作，这可能不会完全消失。但特别是作为一名学生，总是有这种挥之不去的想法，比如，如果我犯了错误怎么办？如果因为我在社交媒体上的存在，我找不到工作怎么办？
And actually, I've got lots of feedback from lots of different people that maybe that's not a really good idea to do, which I do really appreciate because I know that those people really care about me and I really appreciate that they've took the time to think about it and come back to me with that feedback. And there were lots of points that I kind of doubted what I'm doing and thinking about if it's it is a good idea, if I'm being professional, you know, like as a student, there's always this, I think this might not go away fully if someone is qualified and working. But especially as a student, there's always this kind of like lingering thought that like, what if I'm making a mistake? What if because of my presence on social media, I won't get a job?
这实际上是很多人告诉我的。我目前对此的反思是，这就是我，我带着完整的自我去工作。如果有人看到我的个人资料并决定他们不想雇佣我，或者他们不想让我加入他们的团队，因为我谈论神经多样性，我谈论我面临的挑战，我谈论残疾，作为一个残疾人，那么我不认为我想为他们工作。那么我不认为我想在那种实践中工作。
That's actually something that a lot of people told me. And my reflection currently on it is this is who I am and I take my full self to work. And if someone comes across my profile and decides they don't want to hire me or they don't want me on their team, because I talk about minor diversity, I talk about challenges that I face, I talk about disability, being disabled, then I don't think I want to work for them. Then I don't think I want to work in that practice.
我确实认识到这来自于一个特权的角度，能够对一份工作、一个机会说不。我确实认识到了这一点。可能在人生的某个阶段，我不会再有那种感觉了，但我确实认识到我现在也可以说不。他们也可以说不。我的价值是做真实的自己。
And I do recognize that that comes from a privileged point of view to be able to say no to a job, no to an opportunity. I do really recognize that. And possibly at one point in life, I won't feel that way anymore, but I do recognize that now I can also say no. And they can say no. And my value is to be my authentic self.
你知道，我谈论神经多样性的主要原因之一是我在知道自己有 ADHD 的情况下长大。所以我 9 岁时得到了诊断。但我不知道任何人，任何患有 ADHD 并且会谈论 ADHD 的成年人。而且，你知道，我在伊朗长大。所以我 2009 年在一种非常基于缺陷的模式下得到了诊断。你知道，他们回顾了我发现困难的所有事情，并给了我一个诊断。我离开那个诊所时认为我坏了。而且我还被承诺我会长大的。
You know, one of the main reasons I talk about neurodiversity is I grew up knowing I'm ADHD. So I got my diagnosis at 9. But I didn't know anyone, any adults who had ADHD and who would talk about ADHD. And, you know, I grew up in Iran. So I got my diagnosis in 2009 in a very deficit-based. You know, they went over all the things that I found difficult and gave me a diagnosis. And I left that clinic thinking I'm broken. And I was also promised that I will grow out of it.
然后我没有。我没有长大。我 18 岁了。我醒来，你知道，我仍然，我仍然有同样的大脑。这相当令人失望。别误会我。这非常令人失望。但是是的，我在 LinkedIn 上谈论它，因为我不知道你可以成为一名医疗
And then I didn't. I didn't grow out of it. I turned 18. I woke up and, you know, I was still, I still had the same brain. And it was quite disappointing. Don't get me wrong. It was very disappointing. But yeah, I'm talking on LinkedIn about it because I didn't know you can be a healthcare
专业人员并且患有 ADHD。对我来说，把这一点说出来比别人可能怎么看我更有价值，我确实认识到在医疗保健领域工作时，情况可能会非常不同，你知道，希望作为不同领域的助理心理学家，肯定当我在房间里时，我正在与那个人和那个个体一起工作，这是关于他们的，但与此同时，我没问题让他们知道我有 ADHD，我有阅读障碍，我可能患有自闭症，但我确实认识到不同的人对此有不同的看法，我自己的看法随着时间的推移也发生了变化，所以是的，我很想听听你对此的看法，以及你对此的经历。
professional and have ADHD. That is a bigger value for me to have that out there than what someone might think about me and I do recognize when working in healthcare it might be very different and you know like hopefully as an assistant psychologist in a different field definitely when I'm in the room I'm working with that person and with that individual and it's about them but at the same time I'm okay with them knowing that I'm ADHD I'm dyslexic I'm possibly autistic but I do recognize that different people have different views on this and my own view has changed over time on this as well so yeah I would love to hear what you think about it but and about your experience on it.
是的，所有其他正在收听或观看的人，你知道，在评论中告诉我们。我同意，我想现在越来越多的人选择与我合作，你知道，作为他们的临床心理学家，因为他们参与了我的内容，他们研究并比较了，他们说不，我想要你，尽管或者因为我公开谈论悲伤，我，你知道，在媒体上谈论，我有播客，你知道，我谈论同情心，我谈论我个人的一些育儿经历。他们说，我们把你当作一个人来看待。而且，你知道，这不像当他们和我一起工作时我们是
Yeah and everybody else listening or watching you know let us know in the comments. I I would agree I would want I think more and more now people are choosing to work with me you know as their clinical psychologist because they have engaged with my content and they've studied and they've compared and they're like no I want you and that's despite or because of the fact that I talk openly about grief, that I'm, you know, talking in the media, that I've got a podcast, you know, that I talk about compassion, that I talk about some of my own personal experiences of parenting. They're like, we see you as a person. And, you know, it's not like when they're working with me that we're
朋友。我们不是，你知道，我绝对是一名心理学家，这是一种专业关系。嗯，我永远会先是一个人，然后才是心理学家。所以我希望某人能够，我想这是私人执业，你知道，好处是人们能够选择他们想和谁一起工作，他们能够选择我。然而，你知道，如果你在就业中，你知道，你并不总是得到那个机会，对吧？所以，是的，人们正在选择我，你知道，然后我必须不负众望，你知道，有时就像，好的，好的，我会尽力的。但是是的，他们喜欢我所说的和我所代表的。而且我认为我的正直也是，我不会太狂野。
friends. We're not, you know, definitely I am a psychologist and it's a professional relationship. Well, I will always be a person first and a psychologist second. And so I would want somebody to be able to, I guess this is a private practice, you know, benefit is that people are able to choose who they want to work with and they're able to choose me. Whereas, you know, if you're in employment, you know, you don't always get that opportunity, do you? And so, yeah, people are choosing me, you know, and then I have to low up to it, you know, sometimes it's like, okay, okay, I'll do my best. But yeah, they like what I say and what I stand for. And I think my integrity as well, and I'm not too wild.
无论我在社交媒体上说什么，我总是，你知道，意识到我有 HCPC 注册，我是专业合格的，我显然需要，你知道，不要说任何太离谱的话。所以我确实尽量把这一点放在心上。我也会敦促你们，你知道，当你们考虑在社交媒体上发帖时，也要把这一点放在心上。所以虽然你现在可能没有资格，但你希望将来能有资格。我们所知道的是，它并不完全像旧时的报纸，你知道，数字足迹可能会永远存在，特别是如果有人截屏的话。
I'm always, whatever I say on socials, I'm always, you know, aware that I have an HCPC registration, that I'm professionally qualified, and that I need to obviously, you know, not say anything too outlandish. So I do try to hold that in mind. And I would urge you guys, you know, when you're considering posting on socials, to to hold that in mind as well. So whilst you might not be qualified now, you would hope to be qualified in the future. And what we know is that it's not quite like the newspapers of old, you know, that a digital footprint can potentially last forever, especially if someone screenshots it.
所以，是的，尽量保持谨慎和尊重，你知道，只要找到那个正确的平衡，我认为是非常重要的。是的，我完全同意。谢谢。谢谢你的分享。所以你简要地谈到了，你知道，你可以是神经多样性的并且是一名健康专业人员吗？我会说绝对可以。我不知道你是否听说过或者甚至读过。有一本书是 Nikita、Vicki Jervis 和我一起写的，叫做《自闭症选集》（An Autistic Anthology）。它是关于自闭症健康专业人员现实生活中的反思。所以如果有人说，哦，我不知道这些事情可以结合在一起，
And so, yeah, just try to be mindful and respectful and, you know, just find that right balance, I think, is really important. Yes, I completely agree. Thank you. Thank you for sharing that. So you touched on it briefly about, you know, can you be neurodivergent and a health professional? I would say absolutely. I don't know if you've heard of or maybe even read. There's a book that Nikita and Vicki Jervis and I wrote put together called An Autistic Anthology. And it's about real life kind of reflections of autistic health professionals. And so if someone's like, oh, I didn't know that these things could align,
那么请务必查看那本书。Shirin，在我们结束之前，还有什么我们没说但你认为我们应该说的吗？我首先想说那是一本很棒的书，我已经读过了，我很喜欢。我认为这关乎做你自己，我认为不同的人在社交媒体上有不同版本的自己，有时，你知道，我们确实会上 LinkedIn，我们看到人们获得了很多奖项，我们确实看到人们在做几十个，你知道，真正酷的事情。这也会，你知道，这会影响我们如何看待自己以及我们对自己有多同情，特别是，你知道，在心理学领域。我觉得我们做了很多工作，有时这并不总是被认可。所以我也想
then please do check that book out. Shireen, is there anything we haven't said that you think we should before we finish? I first wanted to say that's a great book and I've read it and I love it. And something I think it's about being you and I think different people have different versions of themselves on social media and sometimes, you know, we do go on LinkedIn and we see people getting lots of awards and we do see people doing tens of you know, know, really cool stuff. And that can be also, you know, that can impact how we see ourselves and how compassionate we are towards ourselves, especially, you know, in field of psychology. I feel like we're doing a lot of work and sometimes that's not always recognized. So I would also like
提醒人们，人们在没有获奖时，在申请某事而没有得到时，在申请硕士而没有得到时，在申请博士时，他们通常不会发帖，我们越来越多地看到人们也在谈论这一点。但我还想提醒我们，你知道，我们选择展示自己的哪张照片。我们在 LinkedIn 上发帖。我们在社交媒体上发帖。所以有点像提醒每个人对自己保持同情，并将其视为灵感，将其视为你可以申请的不同事物的可能性，或者，你知道，你可能感兴趣并且以前从未想过的事情，比如，你知道，TED 演讲或加入，
to remind people that people don't often post when they don't get an award, when they apply for something and they don't get it, when they apply for a master's and they don't get it, when they apply for a PhD, we are seeing more and more of people also talking about that. But I also want to remind us that, you know, we choose what picture of ourselves. We're posting on LinkedIn. We're posting on social media. So kind of like reminding everyone to be compassionate towards themselves and see that as inspiration, see that as possibility of different things that you can apply for or, you know, things that you might be interested and you've never thought about it before, like, you know, a TED Talk or joining,
你知道，一个慈善机构。我还想说另一件事，那就是开始关注不同种类的医疗保健领域的人，所以不仅仅是 LinkedIn 上的心理学，因为你可以获得很多机会，你可以从医学生正在做的事情中获得灵感。我认为医学生是值得关注的了不起的人。他们正在做很多非常艰苦的工作，
you know, a charity. And I also just wanted to say one other thing is to start following people in different kind of like healthcare, so not just psychology on LinkedIn, because you can get lots of opportunities, it can get inspired by what medical students are doing. I think medical students are amazing people to follow. They're doing lots of really hard work
看到他们正在做的不同事情总是，你知道，非常鼓舞人心。但是是的，对自己保持同情。是的，非常好的建议。我真的很喜欢参与 Ali Jaffe 博士的内容。她是一位精神科医生。而且，是的，我喜欢和精神科医生聊天。而且，是的，就像你说的，其他在心理健康不同领域工作的人，
and it's always, you know, very inspiring to see different things that they're doing. But yeah, be compassionate towards yourself. Yeah, very good advice. I really like engaging with Dr. Ali Jaffe's content. She's a psychiatrist. And, yeah, I like chats with psychiatrists. And, yeah, like you said, other people who work in different areas of mental health
因为它可以通知我们并减少我们的偏见，而且，你知道，你可能也会和某人建立那种联系。Shirin，非常感谢你的时间。这对播客来说是一次非常有趣的对话。人们确实会给我发信息，他们会说，你有工作吗？我说，没有。没有，我没有。但是是的，我确实欢迎人们向我推销，并告诉我他们是否喜欢我的内容，
because it can inform us and kind of reduce our biases and just, you know, you might have that connection with someone as well. Shirin, thank you so much for your time. It's a really interesting conversation for the podcast. People do message me and they'll say, have you got any jobs? And I'm like, no. No, I haven't. But yeah, I do welcome people pitching to me and kind of telling me if they like my content,
那总是被允许的，对吧？所以是的，LinkedIn 是我日常工作的关键部分。我会说也许每周五到六天。我会在某个时候上线。所以，是的，请一定要来和我建立联系。Shirin，人们怎么能在 LinkedIn 个人资料上找到你？他们怎么能关注你？你欢迎建立联系吗？
that's always allowed, right? So yeah, LinkedIn is a key part of my daily. I'd say maybe five to six days a week. I'm on there at some point. So, yeah, please do come and connect with me. Sharin, how can people find you on your LinkedIn profile? How can they follow you? Do you welcome connections?
你更喜欢关注吗？给我们讲讲。是的，我总是对建立联系持开放态度。我总是乐于交谈，你知道，如果有什么你认为我可以帮忙的，给我发个信息。我总是乐于交谈和分享我的经验以及任何事情。我热爱研究。所以如果有任何与研究相关或与多样性相关的事情，只需给我发个信息。我总是回复。
Do you prefer follows? Talk us through that. Yes, I'm always open to connection. I'm always up for talking, you know, if there's anything that you think I can help with, send me a message. I'm always up for talking and sharing my experience and anything. I love research. So if there's anything research related or diversity related, just shoot me a message. And I always reply.
完美。如果有人想建立联系，详细信息在节目说明或描述中。非常感谢你的时间，Shirin。谢谢。谢谢你的邀请。非常感谢我们的嘉宾 Shirin 向我们推销那一集。我希望你觉得它非常有帮助、鼓舞人心。它是否激励了你加入 LinkedIn，或者如果你已经在上面了，是否激励你刷新你的个人资料？一定要来和我建立联系。
Perfect. If anyone wants to connect, the details are in the show notes or in the description. Thank you so much for your time, Shireen. Thank you. Thank you for having me. Thank you so much to our guest, Shireen, for pitching. that episode to us. I hope that you found it really helpful, inspiring. Has it inspired you to join LinkedIn or to refresh your profile if you were on there already? Do come and connect with me.
我是 Marianne Trent 博士，请让我知道你是从播客上听说我们的。如果你认为我们提到的书会有帮助，这里是。它叫《自闭症选集：心理健康专业人员的神经叙事》（An Autistic Anthology, neuro-narratives of mental health professionals）。它确实是一本可爱、鼓舞人心、大开眼界、有趣的书。你可以在亚马逊上购买，或者你可以直接点击描述或节目说明中的链接。你对你认为有用的播客剧集有什么想法吗？当然，如果我们继续录制，它将算作传播。所以也要记住这一点。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。如果你也想让自己更进一步，为什么不考虑查看“有抱负的心理学家会员资格”（aspiring psychologist membership），
I'm Dr. Marianne Trent over on there and let me know that you heard about us on the podcast. If you think you might find the book we mentioned helpful, here it is. It's called an autistic anthology, neuro-narratives of mental health professionals. It really is a lovely, inspiring, eye-opening, interesting book. You can grab that on Amazon or you can simply click the link in the description or in the show notes. Have you got ideas for podcast episodes you think would be useful? Of course, it will count as a dissemination if we do go ahead and record. So bear that in mind as well. Thank you so much for being part of my world. If you're also looking to get yourself a little bit further ahead, why not consider checking out the aspiring psychologist membership,
你只需每月 30 英镑即可加入，没有最低期限。来自纽卡斯尔。我只是想对《临床心理学家集体》一书的贡献者表示最大的感谢。我非常喜欢读这本书，也很喜欢深入了解在申请博士之前人们拥有的各种背景和经历。看到申请的潜在障碍以及我如何尝试解决这个问题也非常有趣。我真的开始怀疑自己，怀疑自己是否足够好去申请临床心理学博士，但这真的给了我我所需要的信心提升，去尝试一下，所以最大的感谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子以发表评论。
which you can join for just £30 a month with no minimum term. from Newcastle. I just wanted to say the biggest thank you to the contributors of the clinical psychologist collective book. I've enjoyed reading this so much and loved having an insight into the range of backgrounds and experiences. People have prior to applying for the doctorate and it's been really interesting seeing the potential barriers to the application as well and how I can try and work around this. I really started to doubt myself and whether I was good enough to apply for the clinical psychology doctorate, but this has really given me the confidence boost that I needed to give it a shot so the biggest thank you ever. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您每月只需支付30英镑即可加入，且没有最低期限要求。来自纽卡斯尔。我只想对《临床心理学家集体》一书的撰稿人表示最衷心的感谢。我非常喜欢阅读这本书，也很高兴能深入了解人们在申请博士学位之前所拥有的各种背景和经历。了解申请过程中潜在的障碍以及我如何尝试克服这些障碍，真的非常有趣。我曾一度开始怀疑自己，怀疑自己是否足够优秀去申请临床心理学博士学位，但这本书确实给了我所需要的自信，让我决定试一试，所以真的非常感谢你们。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。